[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what inch oh you know we don't need an
inch no we are the intro flying crazy
today it's with Mortal Kombat 11 how's
it going pretty good I am excited to
actually get my hands on this game play
this game in little bits I mean I've
been playing a lot of fighting games but
Mk just hasn't been on the docket but
now it is and today it is and for
everybody else at home tomorrow will be
on your docket too because exactly
that's when it's coming out tomorrow
heck yeah yeah we're gonna we're gonna
check out kind of a little bit of
everything and try to answer questions
for you guys if you have any what's
going on with the game
cuz Hugh bar goes up you could check out
our view progress that's up we've got
all the fatalities already done I almost
killed myself getting the fatality so
it's there please check them out for
sure yeah here we get me the roll it
over into the gameplay for you if you're
feeling it let's really get into this
right now yeah yeah MK 11 we're gonna go
through a bunch of different modes with
you guys and then later on play some
matches against each other
would you have fun so feel free to ask
us questions what do you want to see
we'll try to you know get as much of
that onto the stream as possible we kind
of glanced over it but I'm pretty sure
this has been yeah so I get so excited
by Mortal Kombat forgot about
introduction but yeah so what I'm
planning to do is we're gonna hit up
story a bit then we'll jump into the
Crypt I've got a whole bunch of money to
spend bernal hole in my pocket will open
up some chests classic towers we might
check that out do some towers of time
check out customization that kind of
thing but for the story we're all going
to do the beginning we're not gonna
spoil anything or anything like that
we're just gonna go right from the
beginning yes I'm making sure the game
volume is up a little bit because this
game the audio is just as good as oh
yeah every punch every hit every blood
splatter sounds so good
try not to talk too much over these
cutscenes when they happen because
they're very good
[Music]
some upset people screaming
Raiden's doing his thing do it
punished Radin is a heck of a thing
[Music]
you tell him drag him Rayden
[Music]
but you wear my amulet finally you
embrace the truth the elder gods deny
the truth I was cast out for speaking
the truth I embraced shinnok is that
mercy is wasted on those who defile
birth realm I will destroy our enemies
before they destroy us starting with you
not even you can kill an elder God
chopper watch him though
it's very dramatic as it should be yeah
yeah I can't believe Raiden just
murdered that man but wait he's not
murdered Sears says the only raid and I
know as a cyborg ninja that spits hot
memes it's a good Raiden - that's right
I'm not raiding different losses head
over
[Music]
we just cut the man's head off and then
teleported away like hold that oh the
brain it stops who could this be
[Music]
weird
[Music]
God like Mortal Kombat that was godlike
I really because they did that launch
trailer with the remixed version of the
movie theme and I kind of kind of hope
that shows up at some point in the game
yeah
a little bit of Johnny Cage right from
the beginning that's how you know it's
gonna be good of a very strong Johnny
Cage bias people people probably already
know we've pushed back shout calling
defeated shinnok yet none of our
victories have come without cost
recently commander Jackson Briggs was
honorably discharged his wounds both
physical and psychological left him no
longer fit to serve we honor Jackie's
father and we honor his sacrifice by
doing what he would do yeah realm
sergeant cage step forward your
leadership and war fighting ability have
earned you promotion to commander but
there are no family favours here by
Special Forces tradition you still have
to pass one last test say look I might
be your mom and your dad might be
sitting there smirking behind me but
you've still got to kick my ass to prove
that you're good enough no easy routes
here all right yeah so here's our first
matchup get a fight mom
that's a little disrespectful I think
Mother's Day is coming up yeah fine
I like this modern day you know like
where the son plays basketball with
their father and then they grow up to
like keep them one day it's like modern
day version of that Sony please no
that's your job this whole like the
whole bit shouldn't have made them have
like family members it's really weird to
watch Sonia choke it out oh I mean it is
more combat it is more to look on that
not every family is perfect this is true
I'm sure behind all this there's still
some love there yeah well she's people
are doing this because she she cares
about her daughter she says slow down
yeah yeah you don't in k-11 this is
coming out
Mariana tomorrow so make sure you get
prepared for all this action and we're
going through a story about is our first
fight the story mode so far
Ben we're gonna hold it down we're
playing through story mode but a few
mechanic things you might notice we have
two different types of meter gauges now
I got defensive and offensive those
meters regenerate over time naturally oh
did I beat my mom often she's all proud
of you dude it's it's a real milk your
solid 5 kind of thing we're like you
just eat the crap out of someone and
they're like thanks boss perfect
I literally just cracked all your
intestines but get over here yeah yeah
starring in yet another ninja mime
sequel this is what duty I need to
provide for you and the man into which
you've become accustomed Oh
I'm right here yes same actually
hey that's endearing I love Johnny Cage
so much it's like Raiden superpower
you'd think it's lightning but it's
actually showing up when he's not
supposed to interrupting precious
moments they've been polluted we must
strike them preemptively says no kiss
for Eid Yeah right he teleported all the
way out here just now leaving hands yeah
destroy it and their undead army will
fall removing its threat to earth realm
aren't your powers weaker in the nether
realm yes but I will have sufficient
strength to occupy the undead army is
enough time to infiltrate the Cathedral
destroy it from the inside we get pinned
down in there there's no way out to
ensure earth realm survival
y'all ready it's Mortal Kombat let's do
it weird you know what time it is two
years too much of your brown and gritty
makeover droning on about sacrifice you
don't have a family to lose damn
Jonathan came no she hadn't aware it
hurts
Raiden's right Johnny we're not ready
for another war we've got to take out in
other realms are me now before Liu Kang
can bring it here
oh you do like me in 20 minutes of this
you don't want to get too far any more
spoil too much yeah we'll leave some for
you that and there's there's so much
content with a k to check out we can't
spend too much time in one place
[Music]
that's a lot of dudes
[Music]
we're in position Braden's planned one
hell of a diversion I don't think she
needed a radar you see ah looking at my
scanner I can see that we're clearly out
of luck
hey that readin it's true
I just wanna be so great all this voices
echoing know he's ready no fear Auden
giggy's not even doing anything this
points to see any OG can't believe this
Lu Kang and katana gotta come out and be
like what the heck is this
they got a lot of good yeah they do
special forces got to go up and actually
do something I got this
oh thanks okay yeah sure easy peasy
thrashing it's not trash in the game
it's just kind of like like I love it
I'm having a fantastic time but also
like you need to pull out a thing to be
like wow there are 200 guys over this
cliff it's kind of silly but Mortal
Kombat silly that's its thing that's the
charm yeah that's that's a big positive
but I'm sorry if you got confused and
thought that we were trashing it says
definitely not the case
why didn't they send Johnny Cage he's
got to make a movie he's providing for
his family now so they got him hooked up
to the wall powering the entire building
aw jeez this game's not for you and
that's that's fine no not every game is
for everyone but I'm glad that you here
and checking it out either way yeah
thanks for joining us cabal the gas man
oh it's that easy
I got Lego I love everyone's like new
designs pretty much yeah
I also like that they found a way to
kind of like do good variants on the new
versions and also the Bolivarian
versions yeah this cars fool you he's
fast
take out him and Jade I'll go downstairs
and set the c4 he is fast that is this
thing it's a positive i disgust you
that's my thing man I love being
positive
say we've been running low on violence
someone's got to stab someone
yeah like gotta get ready to take care
of business here
let's head key function without his body
that's how strong yes riggers guys call
you there we go okay - yeah yeah yeah
yeah go Bucky don't women okay okay I
sometimes say like as soon as I start
hitting the the towers that's that's
when the real stuff kicks off those
towers are very challenging
beep easy one more round yeah yeah this
is this is it's in the bag already say
though I missed my Cassie cage variant
playing this one she's missing like to
the attacks that I use yeah so if you
guys don't know each character you can
set up a barian you can pick additional
abilities it's per variant some
abilities might take up one slot or two
slots but you get three slots to fill
the new abilities you can enhance your
character and all of these abilities
actually be really cool stuff and really
different stuff so I'm pretty interested
to see how that plays out in competitive
play yeah yeah Jackie where's Jade she
bailed getting help I'm sure general how
we doing all right so maybe we'll let
this cutscene play out then we'll jump
into the crypts yeah the cutscene
they're a lot longer than yeah ten more
minutes we needed to be tail lights in
five while we're in the [ __ ] now
it sounds like it's not something
friendly yeah yeah I love one points off
the transition from the cutscene into
the gameplay I love how the bar is kind
of pull back in the UI yeah yeah there
we go now we got the swords out
[Applause]
seems like they gave a lot of characters
like a moment where they kinda like just
beat the [ __ ] out of a bunch of things
be reminded why they're cool and why
they're just holding it oh you can't
little classic tripwires
Oh site didn't think we could come from
above
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a lot of voice
nailing movies
oh never mind maybe not a nail that kind
of thing
okay Melinda yeah they're doing all
right
at least they're funneling them through
the doorway that's yeah they've got a
very good choking setup Oh watch the
blink those reactions
[Music]
armed guns or the kid doesn't seem like
I want why'd it take us this long for
more economies in Turkey with armed guns
no he's a good dodge yeah she's really
cool are you play this one out
Wood are you everyone get MK 11:00
tomorrow if you'd like this either let's
see if Cassie manages to beat katana
you've got to pick up the story where we
left off I feel like I was good even
really spoil too much we gave you a good
taste of it yeah see how awesome these
graphics were the animations everything
is so beautiful transitions into game
play very nice very smooth but uh now
it's time to head into the Crypt say you
just spent a long day playing through
the story and they're like you know what
here's some here's some spending money
go spend your coins with a K in the
crypts and unlock some cool things this
is where you get brutalities fatalities
customization options and it's all set
up kind of like a weird adventure game
there's a lot of puzzles you can solve
you get different tools you get Shao
Kahn's hammer you get Ken she's bandana
what you can actually wear which
actually helps you see hidden
passageways and things you might ask why
I swung the hammer as soon as I put it
on it's because that's where one of the
jump scares happens so anytime you you
have a chance to put on the mask an
enemy could pop out and instant kill you
oh jeez
but if you do manage to take them out
you get rewards also these are a thing
to look out for The Chronicle will put
down these random
I'm trusts they didn't have a Krypton
the last iteration to rate was that the
first time that we added up here was it
coops been around for a bit but this is
the first time it's kind of been like
like you run around like this right yeah
yeah in the last one you could move kind
of like in a grid yeah and the other
really cool thing is I've actually been
saving up a whole bunch of the the Green
currency so I can do this but people
might recognize this as the the pit
stage so basically we're on shanks wings
island all of the maps exists here
there's a lot of references to the
movies the one that I keep telling
everyone about that I've been freaking
out about I can finally tell everyone
else because the embargoes there's this
item which we can't see the thing for it
right now if you switch over to gameplay
really quick just there you go you can
see that it's called the element that
brings life and if people remember all
the way back to 1995 in the Mortal
Kombat movie katana throws Luke hanging
down in the sand on the beach during the
fight and whispers into his ear to win
your next fight you have to use the
element that brings life which is water
so in the next fight that he has with
sub-zero he actually uses a bucket of
water to kill him and this is that
bucket of water Wow
so there's a lot of interesting kind of
things linking back to that interesting
something inside my brain is just like
water killed sub-zero yeah which is
weird because you'd be like oh the
community lakes ice does that make but
so they've got little things like that
that are kind of hidden around and
really cool but so this is all new area
for me that I'm exploring we're all
we're all checking it out together might
open this
you got to use currency for like opening
up doors yeah smash these things these
are the chests that have like the really
cool like find fatalities you'll find
customization options once you spend
hearts on I just got a cabal thing that
looks like it's got sunglasses and teeth
so that's exciting yeah yeah so the
hearts are very hard to get because you
get them by either doing brutalities or
fatalities
you only get one per fatality too if you
do a brutality in each one of those
chests costs 250 so let's say it's a bit
of work you can also find them through
other ways I'm gonna go down into two
Goro's a layer which is kind of a really
cool place with a whole bunch of stuff
in it also I finished a challenge
earlier that gave me another piece to
open up this big door that'll be a thing
that we can kind of hit up where's the
oh it's I gotta go the other way just to
open up these chests in here so
basically you just go around you solve
puzzles you admit chests to get
unlockables you get severed shinnok arms
you can use as consumables in this hour
so they're all cosmetic there's nothing
really that you can find in here that
say gameplay-wise super super different
that like changes anything in vs. yeah
it's all just kind of like you get your
your art here your concept art you get
your skin's I can get more currency to
spend in more places so like we get the
concept art problem prop models that
kind of thing
probably won't spend too much time in
here just to kind of get like
may unlock some some things because
after this we can checkout customization
and maybe equip some of the stuff we got
so I got a whole bunch of Shao Kahn
stuff even though we don't have access
to show yeah I'm just waiting from the
to show up we got Johnny Cage my boy
showing up with a K of course that's the
that's the joke the whole time what are
the animation effects look like God war
and you get 50 hearts and 50 so that's
pretty good it is pretty similar to God
a war in a way well just give me a whole
bunch of skins now I didn't I can get
all these before because the stream is
why I guess so it's it's there look at
Boone's watching right now and he's like
get him everything good
got another brutality well so got these
puzzle chests already solve a puzzle
together spend anything on gives you
kind of more stuff that way I've got a
whole bunch of premium currency bring a
hole in my pocket to I find time to
spend that on something so it lets you
kind of get immediate access to like a
revolving store
different skins customization options
but I don't think it was up until this
morning if I gotta do too much upside oh
heck yeah more sunglasses more belt
buckles this is exactly what I'm here
for
yeah yeah this whole preview was worth
it is Johnny gear it's it's all I was
here for everything's worked out but
before we head out of here I'm gonna
show off Goro's lair because it's the
whole underground there's a lot of cool
stuff down there that I won't I won't
spoil too much but there's actually like
cool stuff yeah just go down here and
flip the switch and we head on down also
I'm kind of wondering when this crypt
adventure like takes place cuz there's a
lot of weird character things that don't
make sense you actually find other
Mortal Kombat characters down here
because if you look up kind of in the
distance it might be kind of hard to see
on the stream we're walking up on them
but actually down here in Goro's lair is
Goro actually dead on his throne like
just hanging out which you can see in
the in the actual versus map that takes
place here anyway so I'm not too worried
about that being exploiters we've
already all seen it but you can go all
over the place I think over this way is
the the dining hall area that I think
might actually be a thing from the the
movie I was actually looking to watch
the the 1995 movie this weekend to kind
of just like remind myself of all of it
but yeah just a whole bunch of really
cool stuff open up chests find cool
things but get the loot yeah so go go
out and solve puzzles in the crypt go
find yourself some more Johnny Cage belt
buckles it'll be a great time all that
swag yeah alright so next thing check
out some customization so we got some
cool parts yeah this is a cool I think
it's pretty cool elements
add it to this game so I'm just gonna go
into my Johnny loadout that I got right
now because I've actually got some some
more or access to more things so
basically when you get gear you can
level it up so right now I've been using
these sunglasses for a while I've
unlocked both the oh that's awful and I
love it I you can unlock different
modifications to augment it so right now
I've got the boulevard brawler thing
which makes us let my was a combo move
that he can do and it basically
increases the damage so you get like
little modification things for that too
much to play and level up your gear also
I just love that like when you go to
mess with Johnny cages belt buckle it
zooms in on his face hits you with it
yeah Johnny Cage is great he's real real
great
you can also mess with all the skins you
got different stuff we've got the the
ninja mime outfit already going I'm a
right not using it though that isn't me
exactly but somehow they have the
classic versions of characters you can
actually get like classic Johnny Cage
and it actually makes him young and I
think it actually changes some of the
lines that he uses in pre fight dialogue
that's cool cuz like older Johnny Cage
talks differently than younger Johnny
Cage and they have different things that
they kind of call out but you also get
different variants like you get the one
whereas the the t-shirt on or you can
get the one where he's got the jacket on
so it's got it's got a lot of cool stuff
that you can kind of do to to customize
how you look and you've also got the
different intros and you can preview
them if you want to see - Johnny Cage
dies it's someone hi it's it's just dumb
stuff like that you also got your
fatalities you got brutalities all that
and this is this is where it all comes
in though yes you get to pick what
special moves to kind of build your
character out the way you want to do it
so because I'm playing Johnny Cage I've
got his throwing shades move which just
lets him throw sunglasses at people not
very practical but it's very Johnny Cage
I've replaced his flip kick with rising
shoulder that he has in some of the
other games and I also gave him the like
it's like a weird command grabbed that
he can catch people out of the air and
it does like a five hit combo it's
really cool-looking so I like that he's
also got a counter you've got low force
balls and high force balls it's
callbacks to older versions of him the
brass knuckles from 10 and you can
replace your crotch punch with a camera
if you really want it takes up too many
slots for me though and a cool kind of
weird counter punch but and you know
we're not exactly sure what tournament
standard rules are gonna be like you
guys should really check out these
abilities because they changed the
characters completely or it might add a
new element to the character that's
completely different for example you
know I was using a little bit of scarlet
in training mode and like in some
matches and when we mess with her
abilities she has an ability killer
claws yeah this this move right here
it's very interesting it's kind of a
trap it's a little orb of blood and you
know it will stick to the opponent
it's unblockable pretty much like a
stick no matter where doesn't do any
damage but it prevents your character
from canceling into special moves so if
you managed to get that out you and you
get hit you're preventing yourself from
taking more damage than necessary by
shortening their combos and things like
that so there's a bunch of different
moves like this and they have all these
porky qualities and that's really gonna
change what we see gameplay wise so a
part of me really wants to like these
abilities of you turn like tournament
legal yeah you know change just like you
would check your buttons you check your
abilities it might take a little longer
to be fair but if they had like a quick
access mode in the like versus screen
that
yeah be cool if you could like take like
a memory stick in this book this is my
carry-on with my controller or something
because you were assigned a 90 your
account and then I signed in as a guest
but I couldn't access your variants so
it's all about account also but I saw
someone asking if there are any premium
moves that you can buy I don't think so
I think you have access to all the
different moves that you can change
around right from the get-go that's
pretty cool but I think I think I turn
on the camera again nailed it
we're back alright so what time is where
are we at so 11 33 33 uh we can check
out some of these these cool towers now
yeah so we've got classic towers there
is this kind of like here your arcade
and your survival basic stuff we do a
quick run-through of it
why not but the really cool thing is
what I can do is I can actually set my a
I fighter to just run through it in this
way we can we can let it go oh no we're
doing this tower you need to do this
tower good way to answer people's
questions you wanted to ask them but
well I can go back and roll back I'll
roll back I'll go back I just want to
like oh that's my signature thing is
struggling so we can't let them down no
but that is a cool that is a cool option
because sometimes we were just talking
about this you like AI I think games
more recently AI have gotten more and
more you know smart more intelligent
yeah so it's kind of cool to watch like
an AI on its highest like level because
you might not get to see everything but
you will see one or two things that
you're like wow that works
ooh I could do that and then managed to
transform that into something more
viable when it comes a match but
especially for new games coming out
tomorrow you guys ready available
tomorrow MK 11 can be pretty cool so now
we can launch the struggle it's gonna be
much more entertaining here right yeah
I'll answer any question if you guys
have any what do you think so far like
we were mentioning two different meter
gauges got defense and offense so off
offensively you know you can power up
some of your special moves an ax move
guys played Street right or anything
like that you're very familiar with that
and then the defensive moves you get to
wake up options so one's kind of like
anti-air ish and then ones like on the
ground so you can use those to wake up
and you kind of have more options on
wakeup but you know like anything waking
up with that stuff isn't always safe so
the meter regenerates by itself over
time so it's more of like a cool-down
compared to other fighting games right
now where you either take damage or you
you know connect hit here and there and
that will help you get neater a little
bit you have to have like the fatal blow
the crushing blows the fatal blows you
can actually only get those once per
game which is interesting so if you use
that fatal blow in the first round
you're not gonna be able to use it for
rest of the games sometimes you gotta
gotta pick and choose where you use
those pieces yeah
I did see crime asking what my favourite
fatality in the game was and he already
knew it was Johnny Cage fatality like
this [ __ ]
it was like the first one we saw for him
but it's it's so distinctly Johnny Cage
and it does a good job of like breaking
the fourth wall along with just being
funny but I love it
has the game already know it's this
coming out tomorrow tonight at 12
o'clock midnight midnight we're close
we're close he is almost there whose
voice oh so I did change the announcers
voice you can change it to Shao Kahn's
if you do all the training well yes we
are building this on game spotless oh
sorry I had to shell out for a second
it's all good
that's so far this tower hasn't like
seized difficult cuz I'm making the
Andes getting all this practicing right
now for our matches later okay try to go
for brutality here this is one that's
actually really cool
we hope you guys have been enjoying the
stream so far as we go through some of
the cool features of MK 11 in a little
while we're gonna play some matches so
if you have any characters you might
want to see or can't kick here too that
will do them well boy play them try them
up do you can Johnny work with me here
what are you doing okay patience is
virtue you've waited this long
oh the computer we're gonna come back
all so I'm working on this fatalities or
this has been tallies no that's not what
I wanted it should have been a crushing
blow though the brutalities they'll get
you like double the points that if
fatality this oh here we go
I love just the the comedic like splat
sound that it makes though like it's
it's perfect
alright we'll get the look at the
brutality on the next one
yes you got to see it it was fun yeah
so there's one that I unlock that I
actually managed to pull off and I know
exactly how to do it it's just it's
sometimes you get the crushing blow and
you end up or cutting harder than you
wanted to the crushing blows do a lot of
damage turn off the lights is that was
one of the the best intros I've seen oil
a little bit of pop off before the match
I always agree with this
I got yet more these crabs it's the the
important thing for the brutalities are
got to grab them three times the
stipulation yeah this is looking free
definitely got the grabs on lock oh yeah
working down a little bit make sure
we're okay
work with me here come on almost there
yeah there it is with the mic he's got
to do the thing with his action figure
cuz of course Johnny Cage yeah he's such
a character ah so I don't know if that's
been a thing that anyone's seen yet but
that's what I unlock this weekend and I
was pretty stoked about so yeah that's
pretty cool yeah like from the stream of
the game might be a stream thing try
refreshing or lowering the resolution if
you're having problems but doesn't look
like we're dropping any frames so I
don't it might might just be another
thing but yeah try try doing that
what it's interesting divorce in its
natural selection Insecta babe
this one will enjoy your death yeah she
is very creepy but I think that's pretty
awesome that they can capture that her
design is really really good what I
think the fact that it's so gross speaks
to giving me the chills actually because
I can hear the bugs flying around in my
CBGB's in said all her like fatalities
whatever really good connection
not my contract even even though it is
in between rounds yeah she's on so
squishy yeah yeah no perfect let's get
us a lot of just gross
[Music]
you do this one again 19 took up 19 Joe
you okay isola [ __ ] the sneaky middle
finger like a z3 - that's he always
manages to sneak that in there something
yeah as far as some of the MKX
characters and originals who else is
back or knew they got half of the combat
kids to come back so you've got Cassie
and Jackie no comes in though which is
kind of sad I really liked him he is an
interesting character to play most of
the characters from MK 3 are all here
frost is back I can say that because the
embargoes up it was really fun
pretending you didn't know about that
John they're playing Mortal Kombat this
is a cool scene yes so this is an
interesting boss fight because I was
like I guess this was a boss character
she can't get like putting any
statements not like before attacking or
standing so you can even like knock her
down yeah yeah
then she got a coin yeah here we go
and then she's gotta take us to a
completely different stage now we got
dinosaurs I know she's actually gonna do
it right away but here we are
oh I almost thought about saying a t-rex
jokes and then he actually came out and
I was like oh man okay this is gonna be
my might get guy oh yeah well we might
see her fatality which is I guess it's
okay we'll get the one guy best two or
three is chronic let's go when you bring
it in
oh yeah when when this game gets into
things that aren't regular fights it
gets kind of weird which is maybe my
only kind of complaint with it cuz like
when we get into the the time towers
we'll probably see it more but they like
to stack the odds against you hey guys
it looks like the streams a little bit
laggy you go ahead and click that
refresh button and see if that helps by
chance looks like everything is clear on
our end right now disconnected live
we just got by the ultimate fatality
finish them I wonder if that means that
they're putting something up maybe maybe
we can grab Shao Kahn or something yeah
this is all there it's going to check
really quick see now we'll never know if
you completed that we got an adventure
ok it's not there yet that's fine I
guess now that we're having problems
with the internet and connecting to the
game it's definitely the best time to do
the thing that is definitely tied to the
internet so alright so I did that this
is like the so they have the like
teamfights back
so you actually match make with two
other people to fight like a boss
version of Sub Zero I finally got it
yesterday and it was very intense we can
try that out if there isn't another one
see we got that it's all good
yeah so we got some stuff for Jackie
that's cool too and some more stuff for
we should probably do this there's only
four of these but this is the perfect
time actually to do this for real to use
my AI fighter so you can see some real
Johnny Cage gameplay and also I can have
it run while I can still talk to you
guys
my co-host has stepped out for a bit but
that's okay yeah how's it going need to
see team deathmatch or team match might
be able to find one of those maybe I can
try to just matchmaking to it again just
to kind of show it off
well we'll do it we'll do them that
after this no one cares about Jack your
cats
I love Cassie and Jackie's road side oh
I don't agree with that at all it is
broken Johnny Cage pieces are going oh
it's you want to give you the for the
full screen
just for the moment sit enjoy this this
bite how much will the game cost $60
flat that attacked maybe like 64 bucks
yes I board you know it said John Cage
mercy is back I don't know how to do it
though the computer did it to me once
and I wasn't prepared for it and then it
just came together oh yeah
also I'm definitely gonna say that this
isn't me playing this is my fight he was
not really what $60 I don't know I'm
gonna say if you're spending like 25
hours really it feels like this is now a
game for sure I'll do it there we go
what's our movie we'll play tonight I'm
assuming that it's gonna go live yeah
it's a $300 game no no no I don't know
how much this specialist we have that
scorpion mask over they don't know if we
want to bring out at all they sent us
one of the the big collector's editions
of the game so we have the you can't
wear the Scorpion mask but it's there
those little cheesy hey that's that's
the Johnny Cage lifestyle what character
would you love to be DLC there we go
look at that that mask that's the the
real mole combat 11 scorpion mask yeah
yeah yeah
period here mortal kombat fans pretty
cool collectible
who's playing right now I - AI I'm not
gonna own up to it so I could talk to
you guys it's only two fights but so you
could see it cool stuff like that like
bets that's what I set it up but I did
spend so I've been training him up to be
like this this is like my son I cheer
him on
I'm very proud of another time yeah yeah
can we need one take noob is really cool
though he's very different from MK 9 so
I'm trying to get used to him still
getting toasty I'll say I haven't seen a
single posting up my entire time but
I hope that it shows up at some point
look at the hole this popped out game
over man oh there was a weird like DLC
data-mine thing from the switch version
the game that was really interesting
speaking of DLC characters I don't for
anyone else has seen that but I'm way
into it
and then just like that you've you
finished one of the towers and you get
rewards for each tower you you finish
and then it L it also moves to unlock
the next stage of like a four part thing
if you finish all of them you get all of
the rewards over on the left so you won
four DLC you go oh babe I just want a sh
Williams from Evil Dead to show up
because I seriously think you probably
fit in the most in a more combat game
yeah that's one of my favorite things
about the MK games they always have
pretty cool DLC yeah so I think we'll
we'll try this we'll try to match make
with some people to do this teamfight oh
cool
and then we'll we'll kick off into some
vs. yeah this is it's it's an
interesting setup where you have three
people fighting one boss character and
the people who are waiting to come in
have special abilities they can call in
to assess the person who's fighting and
as each person gets beaten it rotates
more people through so it's kind of an
interesting weird cooperative take on a
weird fighting game think it's it'll
make sense when we see it okay but it's
it's definitely challenging and when I
finished it it felt very good
all right so we've got our setup here
it's uh someone's probably playing is
Codel and a person probably playing as
keno and that go to because I'm
painfully predictable top three most
favorite characters Johnny Cage I kind
of likes like if I had to pick between
Scorpion and sub-zero I kind of liked
sub-zero a bit more and even though he's
definitely the grossest boy in the game
I kind of like Kano it's like the way
that he plays all right so now we we've
got the first person's fighting and you
can call in like I can give him super
armor I'll give him so now the person
floats in the air was probably messing
up I don't think your other I don't
think you know either
which with no one if no one knows and
actually helps basically sub-zero this
ball powered up
yeah and sub-zero so it see if your
teammate dives in the next person on
your team like takes a bat so if this
person dies or gonna die I'll step in
and they can then call an aerosol
so it's kind of like a weird just
multi-person bossfight this is fun Lao
is very good really hoping that I'm able
to like pick up the slack and actually
do something on my side too
oh there we go combo so I have Molina
size which will mix up and they also
they're just two successive hits there
we go
oh yeah so the whole thing all they just
realize they can do things and you get
to choose which powers you have OCD so
each person each slot was okay right so
I get to fight now someone bring a full
screen Showtime power up there heck yeah
oh the rocket some sure please so the
real problem is one of the people has an
ability that that hurts me and if they
keep hitting it it's the the frost
missile it'll actually hit me and freeze
me so if they don't realize that what
they're calling in
it hurts it hurts I think it's just to
kind of mix it up so be like oh you've
got to actually pay attention to it okay
he's he's in the last zone he's he
doesn't have his uh he doesn't have his
how you use it on me are Sutton also as
the fight goes on like you see that the
Hale strand happening now to every
single so it just it just stacks yeah
right all at the same time
oh I believe in him you can do it so
much real so that's that's kind of held
those Joe a lot of heartbreak no I'm
down to give it one more go if the other
guy does well we'll do it we'll do this
one more time so yeah we got two minutes
until until we're good to move on to two
verses well well we'll get it we'll get
this sub-zero down for these guys will
make it work yeah I mean I feel like as
long as we keep that first guy alive
yeah yeah if I were able to actually
pull my weight that probably help out
too we're also getting sabotaged
yeah I believe so given that armor
though just just in case yeah
it's that that divekick is so good with
the trees no sub-zero's freeze has
always been an astonishing concept to me
when it comes to fighting in how long
you get frozen armors coming in clutch
man you know he didn't take as much of
sub-zero slices last round though so
there's a long way to go if only there
was a power where you can give your
teammate like so the other guy has it
but he's not use head in the game hold
on though he's he's going for it
that armored gun oh no he use the
missile oh boy here we go okay
oh man all right now you have to carry
the rest of the way show time you got
this I'm ready ready to embarrass myself
yeah
[Applause]
okay she only got a little protection
there oh yeah pushing to the crotch just
just to do it oh no I knew he's going
low but it wasn't quick enough that was
rough anyway that was rough anyway I
much prefer the support role for more
comment teamfights go got him on the
legs happen again apparently
oh my god that the hail the hailstorm
besieged so much and it's really
unfortunate I feel like the third person
in the queue every time yeah like makes
it ten times more difficult
oh no you're encountering a bit of lag
try to refresh my did sweet we had one
drop frame earlier but I think someone
just quit oh they were like no more I'm
tired of this it's yep they just left
anyway that's how group battles work
most of the time can you change the
order so I don't think you can it it's
kind of like who queues in first I think
but uh where he got towers of time
rotating out again doesn't matter cuz
we're going to do some local vs. yeah
nutty I'm ready to bring a fight I think
we've still got your your variant that
you made yes that's all good I added a
new a new move this time yeah that's all
they're cool cool
oh I'll go with I love Johnny Cage for
the first one just to kind of get warmed
up dude you're on the official
tournament stage oh because why not
and then uh and what we're doing this
fight there's anyone you want to try to
see to play that oh I'll go for that
I'll do my best to show you uh it's
already going
oh I forgot everybody so that weren't
x-rays per se but they do have the
crushing blows which is patented John
Johnny Cage pressure it's here
yeah I did like a little bit of a glitch
there my glasses were floating in front
of my face
[Applause]
[Applause]
ah
[Applause]
yeah it's always the last hit of it then
I got the blood thing on me again
KITT KITT oh no oh you gotta gotta go
for the Scott he's got blood all over
his mouth
Charlie why alright so good we got here
who's gonna pick up the net what's
happening so far so we've checked out
most of the modes and for the last
half-hour of the stream we're skidoo
some some friendly punch matches yes yes
we've got a run back by accident got
excited interesting your let's just
let's do a best of three for this let's
do it do it for real cuz this is look
this is probably the best best possible
setup
look Wow
you do a giveaway if I had copies more
comment to giveaway I wish that I could
but unfortunately that's not
forgot to press the black button yeah
it's that it's getting used to having a
button you block again for sure we're
just barely with the toe ah alright
alright just a new fortnight fighter
that's fair that's that's the test lapa
cut I mean I'm here for it whoo that's
not for cut too
[Applause]
oh no I was going for grab too
[Applause]
you knew I was going for it you're like
ah this is definitely gonna jump in it's
the time well I was scared actually oh I
stopped breathing for a second so that's
that's pretty good
[Applause]
pick Paris please a little Paris after
this one
well BR after we get our three out of
the way oh no I can't even shadow kick
through a thing is
oh man yeah yeah hold up hold up
okay okay for beck donax firm it's your
little bit up there you go
I press the wrong with 1 million prison
it's all good
awesome people ask for collected I'll
hit collect thereafter uh we got we got
one each now we've got to do the last
the last set for the last of the set
this is this is the big one so we got
garrison collector in the queue for the
next next fights
[Applause]
because the sunglasses are not a great
projectile which is kind of a sadist
there we go see me some space I need
some breathing room
I know the last ditch effort uh-oh man I
wasn't I wasn't ready when in doubt
shadow kick wondering accounting I was
actually just thinking that John Luke it
sort of sounds like
we check it out though Oh
didn't capitalize it all I was too too
excited about the fact that it actually
landed
[Applause]
bring it home
Johnny Duquesne yes if you change your
ability on some of these characters
it'll like release another movie you
might have had before
yes Charlotte actually has a cool
television I just think I like instantly
as soon as you get some of the punch
line of the joke he's like I know it's
bad but y'all y'all came here expecting
good jokes from Johnny Cage and that was
the first mistake
all right see some do you want doing try
garrison oh you were saying you were
kind of you want to try it I touched him
yeah door like you know I only saw a
little bit of a pic collector because I
was the other one that people are asking
for it I also haven't played collector
like it also they do have preset
variations if you don't want to pick
from one that was already pre-selected
so I guess I will try this one so I
think this is this is one of my favorite
stage it's very pretty
and I almost pick it all the time
because of it seen that emo ninja at the
top people will make clinic it happen
all right okay so we got got what excuse
me ah okay I got like a weird charge of
projectile Oh
what some interesting things San Walzer
[Applause]
Oh for me little wall yikes I said when
I see emo dude I automatically think of
new yeah yeah it is frost that's on top
figuring this out as we go
you said this is this is half of a
learning thing because both haven't
escaped I pretty much like I played this
beef like 25 hours and all I quit is
Johnny Cage so I said no stop the ground
spin it around spin to win
but yet this stage is really
good-looking though I cool I don't
remember anything for this is okay see
if I can see if I can get this one
definitely not disrespect not
disrespectful at all totally legitimate
God you will be the worst as if you do
that you actually is that more
disrespectful than actually getting the
fatality though that's the question yes
I think it might be out of the accident
yeah all right next one I saw people
asking for noob some people ask him for
frost either one of those two some
interesting to you yeah sounds cool
all right frost is the character that
people haven't really seen much of yet
so they'll be a good time I'll go with
some gold gold noob I do like her
costume oh and you can Kontest the
steeps that's true
the game will choose so let's see who
gets the first point I'm gonna go for
the the black dragon fight clothes yeah
Morty going into this mass of the disk
imagine a disadvantage I can't believe
this
he connects my spine real quick YUM
don't let these intros roll so noob
sounds like dr. klahn I can't unhear no
one can convince me otherwise
OOP oh hold on you guys the best
not in there I assume that starfish
because so that's definitely a murder
yeah but you're gonna get up and I'm
gonna be gonna be a okay everything's
fine I got one I got one too yeah yeah
that's that's definitely a Titanic sim
it's a real good
so I have some some new produces some
kind of
oh okay I can't block that yeah I think
it's a what
yes thank you yeah okay so I do have
that memorized I was real proud when I
did that earlier in practicing just
proud of it that just a lot of a lot of
insights that are now out sides that's
that's a thing right who else did you
yeah
we got next lucky
Lucky's asking for Johnny Cage I'll get
back to Johnny Cage well we'll get him
KITT sana I'm down I'll use I'll pick
it's on it alright alright
[Music]
I really wish I could show Shao Kahn
Snee one seems shaggy I see I see Raiden
will look something straight and let's
go to another stage that we haven't seen
an sarin I can't wrap my mind around
Centurion for the life of me
sub-zero cabal we've got to do a
scorpion sub-zero at some point I really
like post up for a second Jojo post
think about it I'm gonna do it
it's a heck of a grab
Green's got these like commands just
making an arm like just enough and I
think through my favorite thing Jonathan
coming in katanas the best girl in the
small combat I believe it oh there it is
an uppercut how's the store more than
them Calum yeah we checked it out a
little bit earlier on if you wanna turn
back the stream right go check it out in
the streams over not too much though
didn't want to spoil it maybe like 20
minutes but it's a very good story
[Music]
man I don't think I've seen write down
back down got it got it got it got it
got cool
all right oh yeah it's just residue King
oh I'll get loose hanging this time
around tonight well from the game
nobody's rumored to be DLC which is
exciting
[Music]
next pre-order would be Shaggy and
Scooby dammit I'd be a Scooby me yeah
I'm down why not
I'm sorry so Liu Kang see people asking
for a super girl balls pretty fun he's
over next Liu Kang got that so much like
the gas man
a lot of stage have we not
[Music]
yeah we might have actually seen most of
them now so it's probably good to go
with whatever going to the desert I'm
gonna try to take it too this is too
much burn it burn it burn it holy cow
uh-huh
oh my god
so I've I've gotten too much practices
liu kang and i know a lot of his like
i'm just trying to figure out the moves
here y'all I'll get leave the bench oh
that woman so the the best move for
cabal like though the one that you need
to know is the back forward axe it's
like his main thing it should be his -
or maybe that Gary there it is that's it
that's that's your life hold them in
place move in the graphics look
fantastic
yeah the character models are really
expressive the game runs are flawlessly
we are playing on a ps4 Pro - burn it
burn it burn it
Oh yikes
maybe I should play Liu Kang more often
okay when I have more than like 30
minutes of m'kay time lifetime time I
felt goosey oh my gosh that was lunch
yeah that was yeah yeah like I like that
that variant I got him is pretty good
right who else we got that we have in
showing you um saw some people asking
well people were asking about Sub Zero
no what no one wants to see Cassie no
one wants to Sonya Oh someone's asking
for Jess Jackson didn't specifically see
anyone ask for her back ah I mean for
Erin black right it's got cowboy hat and
everything
let's go yes
that's three in a row how we get early
access we got early copies of the game
to help do a few coverage and everything
else for it but now the embargoes up we
were able to hang out and show you guys
what we've been doing I just tried to
rush you just slap me ya know get out of
here oh man Wow I promise I played jacks
once before full screen there's money
waste
my neck my everything oh yeah this is a
young Jack's variant yeah well there it
is
she's got so many good mix up
I don't know what that is but you
[Music]
thought I was cool cuz I was ready for
the low and it wasn't enough oh all
right cool cool third round one day
watching this makes you want to play it
can't wait I'm excited for everyone to
get the game also more shameless
shameless self-promotion if you do pick
up the game on PlayStation 4
Gianluca guy will be here Friday to play
with anyone who wants to play with us so
if you're like man these people are
trash I could totally beat them by the
trash you're watching me but also if
you're not very good world combat don't
let the fact that I just called out
everyone who's good at the game deter
you we want everyone to come and show up
we're doing it just for fun it's a good
time coming hangout so you should
definitely subscribe to the channel
and not necessary stream you do Oh God
I'm trying to promo and I shouldn't be
promo my god okay I've been able to get
a single so you can do it from anywhere
downtown for death okay
it's a good talk I'm into it I'm into
that
okay let's give that the inputs are put
the timing for it's like a weird like
it's not fast but it's not slow it's
sometimes just like nah that's useful
all right Oh wrong one I went down two
spots
all right who else you guys want to see
I think we almost covered it except for
the legendary man should we do that uh
oh shoot it's 12:30 let's do let's do
Scorpion and sub-zero and then we'll do
one more with scarlet and Johnny Cage
and then we'll call it a stream all
right cuz that combat cast is coming up
in 30 minutes we got to get ready for it
you want to use scorpion or Sub Zero uh
I'll try some if only I had that
hailstorm and I would really visit take
it - uh there we go there we go oh I did
it I finally go boy oh yeah there were
people asking for collected we played
him earlier yeah
oh I want to see their bathroom actually
I cannot escape my rage
without a doubt Frost and sub-zero are
the coolest characters in there
shouldn't wait for it
oh I did
[Applause]
ya-ya-ya-ya-ya one more time
still can't follow up with that right I
should probably just Oh No Scout I've
been practicing a bit of scorpion
because I've been embarrassed with how
how not good I like them some like there
we go I need to do one of those that
that sort of look like I knew what I was
doing there we go it's the timing for
it's not like universal back then okay
cool I got really far away
oh it's the one from the reveal trailer
dang so it's very in-your-face fatality
like for sure will do will do scarlet
Johnny Cage last match and then we'll
head on out of here and get ready for
that combat casts maybe they'll have
some other cool stuff to show off like
I'm I'm excited Johnny Cage
[Music]
all right last match of the stream and
then we're heading out so enjoy and then
so Friday we're gonna place with the
community here yeah well we'll play well
it's going to Allah be with all you guys
you can join in hang out have a good
time getting beaten up in Mortal Kombat
it'll be fun
please please
Oh from her side but it is really nice
that she like
[Music]
oh my goodness oh please strings huh
it's such a weird fighting name to play
this like after playing other fighting
game yes it's got that weird like kind
of combo yeah it's not like like you
don't visually confirm what you're doing
in the combo you just got to go for it
you're like I'll cool it hit I can just
hit the rest of the buttons and then
it'll go
the football the origami
Wow that can kill you Thanks okay all
right all right third round that's good
this is good this is a good fight
ah
what a hard time just getting in okay
this was day one 11 well these negative
ones yeah you're right is it's out
tonight tomorrow so look forward to
fighting with everyone else I had a
great time and if you had a great time
you should be sure to subscribe to the
channel so we don't miss you anytime
that you're here
exactly you're here Monday through
Friday at 11:00 a.m. yeah same spot so
please come tune in next time if you
enjoyed the MK 11 play today make sure
you snag your copy because it comes out
tomorrow
yes and come check us out Friday we'll
be playing with the community so I saw
all you talking about huh trash in the
chat me and you guys are very good come
fight us on Friday right bring it beat
me up
bring it all right you know it's all in
fun and games you guys exactly but yeah
that's about it we will catch you guys
next time so thank you so much for
tuning in you're the best and we'll see
you later
bye everybody see you later
you